[Musique]
alors le césar du meilleur acteur dans
un second rôle est attribué à nicolas
marié dans adieu les fonds ce prix
récompense une magnifique histoire
d'amitié et de fidélité
albert dupontel ennemis sont rencontrés
au tout début des années 90 en jouant la
voir ensemble au théâtre de la porte
saint-martin il a joué dans tous les
philippe dupont talent à réaliser mais
c'est ici sans doute qui trouve son eau
le plus fort et le plus étonnant un
aveugle archiviste échappé de son sous
sol
[Musique]
merci albert dupontel pour ce joli
cadeau merci cher albert pour toutes ces
années d'amitié de fidélité
professionnels et destine partager merci
à catherine bourgault merci à la gaumont
merci à mon agent jean luc darier pour
ses 35 ans de complicité
et puis ce césar doit le partager avec
celle que j'aime je dois le partager
avec marguerite avec emilie et avec
marie
sans elle ce césar n'aurait pas de sens
merci à vous merci
[Applaudissements]